what's up guys today I'm checking out a
very special motherboard that lies
within the ROG family that offers almost
all the same features as the older
brothers but it's up 200 for your next
high-end coffee like build this is the Z
370 Yi gaming from Asus which falls on
the district's family it comes with all
the features that you would want except
for some neat overclocking modes it even
has some features that many other
motherboards in this family don't have
such as Wi-Fi and Bluetooth support
since this is an rog board exercise to
include all the key features that a
builder could want and even implemented
some RGB into the back i/o to keep the
colors quite neutral but the silver
accents would go very well with silver
cases if you want something even more
called neutral you guys should consider
this trick since e3 70f game that
motherboard is basically the same
motherboard is this - Bluetooth and
Wi-Fi it's also free dollars cheaper as
well it doesn't have any silver
highlights which are all replaced by a
shape life
finally on this motherboard there are
some LEDs on the top right that help
troubleshoot different booty shoes
the power face of this motherboard is
ten plus two and the CPU BRM it attended
the face solution overall this
motherboard easily able to handle it
apply beers overclock on the CPU and a
thirty two hundred megahertz overclock
on the ramp economic overclocking as
highest enthusiast sports the only
disadvantage of this board would be that
a wouldn't out press much information
issues all the temperature and stuff
additionally this board has six SATA
ports 2 m dot 2 slots three USB 2.0
headers two USB 3.1 genuine headers and
even a USB 3.1 gen2 header it also has
six PWM fan headers three pcie 3.0 which
all have 16 lanes and a sick m dot two
heats
however the empty slots do share
bandwidth with the s status locks so
make sure to keep that in mind when you
are using that about two slots this
motherboard can support sli or three
respire but if you guys are setting it
to just set up
you guys should buy a hired motherboard
this motherboard comes a supreme FX
integrator audio and supports up to 7.1
surround sound out of the six fan
headers one of them is a i/o dedicated
and another one is meant for an m2 Finn
but you guys can just use that for
normal fit as well all the fan headers
on this motherboard are strategically
placed around the edges and next to CPU
for in order to avoid fan cable from
being nice
asus has implemented temperature sensors
and various places in this board to keep
the user updated on turn their most of
their motherboard on the rear i/o of
this motherboard you can find one DVI HD
41 display 41 HDMI port one land rj45
port that's sports area but either 2 USB
3.1 gen2 at a and type-c ports two USB
3.1 gen2 on which are colored blue two
USB 2.0 ports one optical s/pdif out 5
audio jacks and one asus Wi-Fi go module
and the wine fly supports AC and
bluetooth version 4.1 it also comes with
an adapter overall this is a high-end
motherboard
let's close close to the intuitive level
while offering a much more affordable
price between the Maximus and code
families in my opinion I'll MSI and
gigabytes offer great motherboards Asus
mystic Kingdom credible Edwards and
always incredible and this motherboard
should be on your short list of
motherboards if you guys are planning on
getting the beauty 700k and prefer not
to shell out too much one
if you guys are planning on getting 8600
cake I would say look for cheaper
motherboard guess you guys have a
tighter budget and a little extra
features of this motherboard offered
artwork sacrificing a GPU level or even
upgrade to the East 100k using the money
that you would save from a lower end
motherboard that still offers most of
the features a sport has maybe - the RGB
and a few ports overall this is a
premium motherboard for people looking
for to build a premium system if guys
don't fall in that category I would
recommend you guys buy a different
motherboard this motherboard is build
several bells and whistles and it's
meant for people who have a mentality of
having a premium product or rog product
and don't they have really mind shelling
out a few extra dollars for all of you
guys who are still interested this is an
awesome little boy and comes everything
that you would want if you guys want a
premium product but don't want to go
super high-end then this is the perfect
motherboard for you if you guys are
considering buying this motherboard I
recommend you guys watch my unboxing of
this motherboard if you guys are curious
as what comes in the box
well that's all I have for you guys
today I hope you guys enjoyed that and
if you guys really liked it I would
really appreciate like on this video and
if you guys loved it and would like to
see more of do it just like this please
consider subscribing and pressing that
Bell notification thanks to subscribe
button so that you guys are always
notified when I post a new video I hope
you guys enjoyed that
and learn something along the way but
until next time bye